[музика]
одні
армія барон ok там більше немає раб буран
божих тобто мені хоч би один stinger
витратити на них не вертоліт скейте раз
пояс нього нападаючи сам шматок ти
розумієш нас
Європа штати американо пакували таким
зброєю 6 передач на бруні якщо ти
бачиш на кому з танкує простирадло
простими голос кущів натискаючи кнопку і
вас всіх повз d&g velvet весь інтернет
загибелі
скс бомжі та рауль та
хату путін
стохастик
базуки
і на кого пула його сюди
безодню
[музика]
прийняте тіло бійця російської армії
а хіба в нього була голова, коли він ішов
вбивати мирних людей в Україну заразу
бути кипсале з знайшов два різці калим
символом
цекало що за ну а
палани не вам все за блок у та wanted ви
так будете жерти блять як суші знайдете
блядь мох і роботи мозку варнику зміг
бургер і Макдональдс до маховика
down the milky way
комендант київ сито та будинок
а я зараз вам покажу а я зараз вам
покажу, а я зараз вам покажу звідки на
білоруської
операції не було завдано превентивного
удар по позиціях штирі позиція шанс
покажу карту привіз вони б атакували
наші війська білорусі та росії які
були навчення тому ним і розв'язали
цю війну на совість чиста добре що
почав
так рашисти літати
[музика]
навчилася деш це без маріуполя
область та сохне та плутане погляд
заблокуємо і навіть чому так нікуди
рипнутись не мій нас польша закрила
повністю литва закрила повністю
бік пітера рахунок
[музика]
мирза
ну
[музика]
[оплески]
що
я зараз вам покажу звідки на Білорусь
готувалася напад і їсти
[оплески]
[музика]
я вам зараз покажу звідки на Білорусь
за будувалася на падіння якби за 6
годин і щасливий за 6 годин до операції
не було завдано примітивного удару по
позиціям 4 позиція карту приніс
українські біолабораторії вели
дослідження перенесення бойових вірусів
птахами з 2009 року
[музика]
ширину
та й вікуся і
диверсанти піти
розрубування лабораторія проходів та
вимоги заразна натовських базових разів
сама побалакає
доброго вечора мис україни
[музика]
він підійшов і сказав
йдіть зараз будемо підпалювати будинок але
люди не пішли і все одно він підпалив будинок
він дуже поганий чоловік обама він всю
війну створив у цьому як його в Україні
через три тижні
справа
замахнувся на нашого путіна і навіть не
маєш право це слово вимовляти
[музика]
кордон Росії ніде такий
про обслуговування печі 12 грацію край міг
захистити російську федерацію від військову
базу на
[музика]
куди і скільки сильно класу сі він хотів
відпочити засмагати можемо запропонувати вам
солярій а лише цікавіше є дуже
гарячі пропозиції дев'ять компаній вже
з'їздила ніхто не скаржився все під
загоріли, а як називається курорт вчора
майка
[музика]